Ah,
hey guys.
Hey,
what's up?
Watch.
Your name's white Bandana.
No,
we covered up the,
Oh,
here we go.
Is everyone here at Google and courage to bring their dogs?
You guys,
it's real lives reputation.
Google-Y Mowgli.
So I'll welcome the toxic go guys.
I'm Kevin Valex.
So we have of course,
a deck Sheppard and I'm Michael Pena for chips.
So let's walk on it,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
hello to everyone,
the live stream as well.
Um,
and uh,
so welcome guys to Google.
Phenomenal film,
hilarious.
And dex you wrote,
directed,
produced it and you executive and startle and you guys started.
Hey,
executive.
But I think that's a title at this point.
Oh my God.
I really didn't do anything.
You were really good in the movie.
Thank you.
That was great.
Um,
so where'd you come up with the idea for a,
to making this a translation from the TV series for the movie?
Um,
I was googling,
I really was,
I was writing a different screenplay and I made a Poncherello joke and I don't
know how to spell Poncherello.
So as I often do,
I check my spelling by searching the word or they messed up version of the word.
Can you swear on whatever that we're doing?
I don't even know all we can.
I feel like I'm in the Jetsons.
Right.
So I googled Poncherello and it,
this image of Jon and Ponch popped up and they looked really cool,
which normally they look very seventies and a,
they looked kind of tough and I was like,
oh,
there's like a bad boy's version of chips waiting to be made.
And I just love motor sports and cars and motorcycles and boats and things.
You put gas in it.
So I'm just always looking for some way to do comedy and car stuff.
And you knew how to ride bikes since you know how to ride a motorcycle.
I trained for four weeks and that's all I needed.
You need it to me 30 years,
30 years of writing.
No,
I basically like I wrote a lot when I wrote in it like in a straight line for
most of very well though,
one of the straightest lines have ever seen.
The stunt guys were like,
Whoa,
like got a laser pointer on that right now.
And basically it was just my locked arms and making sure that I don't swerve
into decks.
And you had written and directed a couple of films,
but what made you want to write and direct this versus just starting and it was
just,
you had a passion for the series and thought it was great.
Well,
actually did not think I was going to act in it.
I was just there at Warner brothers to sell them the idea of me writing this
version and then hopefully then they would let me direct it.
Um,
all I knew is I wanted pain Ya.
And then the studio exec said,
okay,
and then you'll play John.
And I was like,
no,
I think you should get a movie star.
Like Chris Pratt or somebody.
And he,
he's rightly or wrongly said,
no,
I think you should do it.
So then I did it.
Yeah.
Wow.
And so how,
how,
it's hard for me to concentrate on this.
Can I just say this because we don't ever interact with folks like you.
I'm actually more interested in you guys then.
I think I'm certainly more interested than I am.
What question or questions you got lifestyle,
you
smoking
weed over here.
Are you incubating,
did you always have a high Iq guys take jet packs here to work?
I mean,
do people dictated read to you or like what do you,
I dunno,
I just,
I,
this is really fascinating.
I'm from Detroit,
which is a very industrial blue collar town,
and this is very think tanky and I was very fascinated by this whole thing.
What is the average age?
What does the mean age here at Google?
Do you know?
Lower than I thought it was.
I don't know what the age,
I don't think we ask ages.
I have no idea.
30 32 of course I'm,
that's that.
It's gonna be an industry leader.
Regular's Club.
Greg learners.
So we seen a Googler,
so Google Googlers,
our employees,
Googlers and all you have Greg learners if you're the of no Googlers.
Little condescending.
Anyways.
Yeah.
So if you've got gray hair and you're a little bit older,
gray colors,
you're Greg [inaudible].
Oh yeah.
It's unlike Google.
Walmart calls their employees partners,
what do they call him?
Something condescending and bullshit.
Marty's like Walmart
associates.
They're not employees.
They're associates as if they own it or something.
I Dunno.
How do you guys go about Googlers?
You're not allowed to say.
That's fantastic.
That makes me feel a lot better because it was an interesting,
not
she loves it because if I had to go by chippies for the rest of it,
no.
Okay.
So we like Googlers,
see this is a good,
again,
we're learning something right away.
I'm going to bring the same fall back to la.
I don't think you have to,
if you just go on Google.
Okay,
great.
Forget that.
I won't bring it back to La.
There we go.
Sorry.
I just,
you know,
help with the segway into the next question.
Um,
oh really?
Yeah,
we,
uh,
so,
so actually going off that then with Improv,
so was that prevalent on the,
on the set guys know,
really stick to the script?
No,
I mean we rehearsed like for four weeks and he was basically rewriting it.
We exhausted every possibility.
So usually he just wrote what he thought was the best.
And nine times out of 10,
that's what it was.
I love Improv in movies that I haven't written.
And then the ones I ride,
I'm like,
this is perfect.
Why would we mess with this?
This is like,
so how do you guys know each other before?
Like,
did you know that you wanted Michael for this?
It was just so when I went to Warner brothers,
I said,
okay,
how about chips?
Reboot.
And it would be like lethal weapon,
uh,
or bad ways.
And he said,
great.
Who would be paunch I and it has to be Michael Pena.
He's the only guy that I think could play punch.
And they said,
oh,
we love him.
Perfect.
Um,
and,
but I,
I did not know Michael,
nor did I ask him if he wanted to be in chips,
but I sold it as him starring.
So when I left,
that mean it was like I have got to become friends with Michael Pena yet asap.
So,
uh,
my TV sister from parenthood,
Erica Christiansen,
I knew was really good friends with him.
So I called Eric kind of panic,
like you've got to tell Pena,
I'm a good person and a nice guy and all the,
and then she did that lovingly.
It was almost like,
but it was kind of an interesting text message cause it was almost verbatim.
He's a really good guy to work with.
And we never talked about business ever before,
but she did tell me that the one thing that I do know about this is that you're
gonna have a blast.
And to me that was worth it.
And like when I met him it was like,
it was a lot of fun.
I was like,
and he's like,
and he said,
he's like,
we'll have a lot of fun and a lot of movies you don't have fun.
So I thought it'd be a blessed,
well this is like the Google experience of film.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Did you guess you would lower on Lex?
I know it's Long Beach in there and oh yeah,
it was all right away.
So,
oh,
sorry.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I talked too much.
You know,
I said Oh yeah,
okay.
That's pretty much money.
Okay,
great.
Um,
so often they make you make movies in other states even if they're set in
California because states offer tax incentives and a rebate,
some of your budget back to you.
Um,
and so we had applied for the California tax credit,
which is really,
really hard to get.
I think the only gay about like seven or eight of them and it's a jobs ratio
number basically that gets you disincentive.
So,
um,
you know,
we were like waiting fingers crossed to find out,
we don't found out like a few weeks before we started filming.
Uh,
cause the backup plan was to go to Louisiana and then we would add to call them
the lips,
which would be Louisiana highway patrol.
And then sound is tough is chips.
Well it's got some great locations and great chasing.
So was there any location that you wanted to do but they wouldn't allow you to
film or do any of your stunts there?
I hadn't written this big action sequence inside of dodger stadium and then we
got the daily rental fee for dodger stadium and we're like,
okay,
we will not be shooting there.
Let's get into a Lesean park and see what we can do there.
That's when you did the bouncy houses and stuff.
If you can't get dodger stadium,
you'd do bouncy house was a no brainer.
Um,
so,
uh,
what was the most difficult scene for you guys to shoot?
For me,
I,
it was a pretty easy shoot.
I mean use a director probably who was it?
Stunts.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And if you,
particularly,
there was,
there's one sequence in the little more than halfway through where this scene
that starts at the drug house and there,
those are chase on Venice beach and then it goes into the La River and then it
comes out onto the sixth street bridge.
And then there's this motor home that gets driven through,
buy a Hummer and then a,
I get hit and then there's an explosion and the,
you know,
all this stuff happens.
And that was really challenging me cause we were shooting on this bridge and we
only have two days to get everything we need on this bridge.
And the two areas of activity are about,
um,
uh,
eighth of them.
Um,
more than that,
they're probably a quarter mile apart.
And when you're filming things here,
it all needs to be happening back there,
a quarter mile away and you only want to look one direction.
You want to look one direction once,
shoot everything you need looking that way and then you want to come around and
look that way.
You only want to do that once.
So trying to map out,
okay,
if we shoot this,
the motor home would not be destroyed.
It would be destroyed.
No,
it won't be destroyed.
And you know,
this working out the math of all the logistics of that scene was pretty um,
intense.
And uh,
Michael,
what's it like carrying a naked deck shepherd that happens by the way?
Oh wait,
you guys haven't seen it?
So somehow somehow makes sense.
Um,
so I'm supposed to carry DAX.
It's in,
it's in the,
uh,
the trailer carry him and then,
cause he has a bad arthritis who needs to be in warm water.
And he calls me out of all people.
So I carry him and then I slept and I face plant into his pubes.
But I put them into the tub.
Um,
and that was pretty tough and actually he's pretty light to be honest with you.
For instance,
three men,
anyone wants to pick me up after this?
I mean physically lift me if anyone wants to offers on the table can also take
my clothes off if you'd like to lift me.
He does like to things gloves.
Um,
if there's a sequel,
where would you take some of these?
With these two characters?
I'm somewhere warm and tropical.
My family would enjoy being always shot I think.
Right.
I think there's a big case in Hawaii.
Yeah.
There's a huge,
huge racing ring in Bora Bora.
We're going to have to break out.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Um,
but yeah,
somewhere,
somewhere exotic.
Did I hear the question right?
If we got to do a second one,
which location but just [inaudible] sure.
Where they would go.
Yeah,
because in the first one it's like,
um,
Harry met Sally.
I'm motorcycles.
So we fall in love in this one.
And then I would really like to explore what it's like after you've been dating
for like a year and a half and you don't leave the house much and you just watch
Netflix and wear sweats and gang 15 pounds.
I think that'd be a fun place to start.
Like the doldrums of a relationship.
Yeah.
Um,
your work.
So do it on this question a little bit because when it hits the mic,
um,
so if you could do one film crossover with like another classic television
series with two characters,
get Starsky and Hutch or whatever,
who would those be?
Those characters being that would be the one.
In fact,
they pitched at the end of this movie that we're chasing somebody and all of a
sudden that Grand Torino blows by us and we're like,
what the fuck is that?
Like I wanted to introduce them in the same world because they were late
seventies la cops,
both of them.
Oh,
almost like the marvel universe.
How some would go back.
He starts getting hodge,
the fall guy,
knight rider,
and it's the hazard could jump through every now and then.
That's a really good,
yeah.
Well actually,
so since you're in the marvel universe,
you play a,
you're,
you're in that man.
And so going off of that,
yeah.
Thanks guys.
Bye for him.
What would,
well,
we got one back.
Who would you cast access in the Marvel universe?
In the marvel universe.
He'd be like,
well we almost,
we almost look like superheroes because of what we have to wear these leather
racing outfit for motorcycles.
I think he plays superhero.
Yeah.
Which character?
You know.
Oh I have no,
I'm not well versed in the,
on the marvel.
Don't say Amanda Steele.
Who would you want to please?
Man of steel.
Just trying,
making the most arrogant thing you could pick for yourself.
Oh God.
He's going to say superman.
Did you have a character you like to play dates?
Um,
well
in full disclosure,
I'm my only awareness of the characters in the marvel universe are the ones I've
already seen in movies.
So,
um,
you know,
unless Downey hangs up that suit and invites me to do iron man,
um,
I don't know.
The Paul Rudd One's neat cause he's more charactering goofy.
And I certainly couldn't.
I don't think I could play just like square job.
Serious guy.
Yeah.
But I would love to play a superhero.
I mean like I'm in that world.
I'm like,
it'd be awesome to have to,
you know,
you become some that I'm pitching them and they're like,
yeah,
that's cool man.
Why don't you just keep doing what you're doing?
Great.
So you bring the jokes and the jokes,
you don't want me to fly or anything.
Um,
and so you worked a lot with the CHP and so how do they have like a technical
advisor on set or they do and your brother's a cop,
isn't it?
My brother's a cop.
Yeah,
for sure.
But we,
I didn't do too much research into the CSV.
No,
not for this role because he plays an FBI agent undercover as a cop.
So he wouldn't really know a bunch of CHP protocol.
And I play a rookie who's intentionally not supposed to know a lot.
So it didn't make sense for us to get super savvy now to write the screenplay.
I had to learn a lot about the CHP.
But um,
as far as the characters,
they,
it was the best if they didn't know a lot.
And in fact when I had meetings with the CHP brass to see if they would help us,
they said they are not following protocol in this movie.
And I said,
people generally don't pay 14 bucks to watch people follow the rules.
There's a rule of thumb,
they kind of like to see you break the rules.
Was there any push back from them saying you should cut that or anything where
they just kind of letting it be,
they had three really,
really simple requests that were not,
I didn't feel like compromise any artistic integrity.
One was,
I had inadvertently like toe by total coincidence I had named the bad guy,
the name of one of their most esteemed
commander,
ray Blackwell.
Apparently there's a famous ray Blackwell.
I just happen to name the bad guy that,
and they go,
we think it's funny like the joke about Ray,
but I think Ray's feelings might be hurt.
And I'm like raise a fictitious.
And so that was just a weird coincidence.
So I changed his name.
That was no problem.
And then also they really pride themselves on being a very transparent
organization.
So originally in the movie it was that the FBI decided they had to go undercover
to find out who the dirty cops were and they said,
you know,
we would,
we would ask for their help.
So if you just see,
and I was like,
yeah,
it saves me like a page of dialogue if you ask,
I can't remember what the third one was,
but it was not very cumbersome.
Is there anything that you learned as a director or even as just a writer on
this film that you're going to take?
Because if you're doing an animated Scooby Doo,
is there anything that you've learned as like a director?
Like,
oh,
well,
like you should remember that for next time,
we're actually not do this.
Right.
Um,
I learned a lot of hard lessons on the first two movies.
This one went pretty darn smooth.
And when I got to the editing room,
I had pretty much everything I needed.
So,
um,
this is by no means to say I've liked topped out at the job.
Just,
um,
I,
the last couple of movies I really learned some lessons.
Like don't let people sit down and talk for a long time.
That gets boring no matter what they're saying.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I guess I am learned the lesson,
all that well,
um,
audience question guys.
Oh,
look at this dog.
Oh No.
Now what have you have odd dog allergies and you work at Google.
Tough Shit.
You're fucked.
That's amazing.
She was right there,
dude.
I work with my husband everyday.
I was curious.
What is it like to work with your wife?
Oh Wow.
Um,
it is my favorite person to work with.
we get along really,
really well,
particularly when working together because typically in a marriage you have here
he goes,
good.
Yeah.
Job
taking care of Mommy.
Okay.
Oh,
he's tired.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Um,
in real life,
you know,
you,
she probably doesn't want to see the movie.
I want to see.
She would probably rather not go on a vacation that I want to go,
you know?
Then there's like endless compromise,
but on a film set you have the same objective every day,
which is a really,
um,
good,
easy thing for a relationship.
So I like it.
This question is for docs.
How does this film compared to other films you've directed and written?
Like in terms of labor processes,
et Cetera?
Um,
and then I feel like this dovetails into Google a bit because this time I had
money and I had a really awesome team of people who are super great at their job
and that made things so much easier.
The Guy,
our,
our director of photography,
he was a second unit DP on all the Michael Bay movies,
the Bourne identity.
This guy had shot thousands of hours of action.
And so the way his brain works was so,
so easy.
She's taking a Selfie of the dog with us.
Oh,
by the way,
that was amazing.
He's like drunk and breaking it down and you're like,
oh,
that was Jane.
I totally met.
So yeah,
no,
I made my point.
And more importantly I made it in his selfie.
Well,
thanks so much guys for being here.
So chips comes out March 24th go.
See,
it's phenomenal.
A lot you guys to like ask them why have some mark,
you've got to go to the microphone now.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But like what's your day like?
Like,
you know,
cup,
a couple hours of work a day.
Anybody,
anybody like you.
Okay.
Like,
what is your day like?
Um,
so I think one of the misconceptions about Google is they have,
so we're really,
really hard.
I no longer like that can work really hard.
So you don't work hard,
you work really hard.
I've been at Google almost seven years.
When I first got here,
it was amazing.
Like there's three cafes,
like everywhere you turn there's free food.
People are like shoving food down your pants all day long.
There there was a free massage or almost free massages,
no massages or gyms.
There's like crazy activities that you get to do like,
um,
opportunities
for creativity and married to my husband.
No Chamber for you guys here on Spiegler.
So when you didn't married your whole Spiegler.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Um,
but yeah,
like Google has done crazy things.
Like I think we got an email one day like,
hey guys,
we rented out a theater for you and it's almost like the Michael Jackson Cirque
du Soleil show.
So we're taking you off to Jackson was here.
That's awesome.
They took us all to slay,
talk to Michael Jackson.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
and like incredibly generous.
Like they run on another campus down in mountain view.
That's our headquarters.
So they run like 10,000 people on private shuttles to and from work every day.
Um,
like trouble.
There's lots of opportunities to travel.
It's like,
wow,
it's a pretty awesome place to work.
But we also work like super,
super hard,
like four or five hours.
It sounds like your ads for you,
so like quite a bit and uh,
eating,
you got to chose an average workday.
When are you expecting to get here and when are you mean?
I think,
well,
speaking on behalf of 30,000 people,
um,
I think it's a pretty flexible place to work.
So that's definitely one of the advantages of Google on people will have
different work schedules.
Some people will get in,
like I think the engineering stereotype is people will roll in like 10 to 12 are
you in the Pr Department?
Uh,
no.
I'm in,
I'm in the engineering department.
Oh,
okay.
Just one of them at 10:00 AM to 12:00 AM 10:00 AM to 12:00 PM you might roll
into,
Oh yeah,
window.
You might leave work like 8:00 PM or later,
but where we want you here eight hours a day,
is that the goal?
I think most people probably on average end up working like 10 to 12 hours a
day.
Like when you average all addictive,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like I think,
I think [inaudible] very driven type of person.
So people are workaholics,
but we hope you enjoy all of our products and that we're making the world a
better place for you.
[inaudible] engineering.
But it was really does anyone to hate this job from someone who wants,
who wants to get fired right now?
[inaudible].